[Music]
do you really think you're ready
your ultimate demise awaits in countless
horrific
ways
[Music]
hello everyone it's lucy here and
welcome back to another broadcast
settle in and get comfy because today is
for the end game elites the hardest of
the hardcore
and for you newcomers that are about to
become hardcore
get ready for what's coming in outriders
world slayer back in april we first
revealed what worldslayer is bringing to
the table with a full new campaign new
patch trees apocalypse tears ascension
points and loads of loot there's tons of
tasty content to gorge yourself on in
outriders world slayer you will face off
against the indomitable oreshkagal
but even if you do manage to beat her
you've just opened the doors to even
greater horrors in the trial of tarja
gritar this brand new dungeon experience
will offer you hundreds more hours of
gameplay and truly push you to the brink
of your controller's lifespan
before we get into the nitty-gritty
details on the extraordinary end game
we should kick things off with a trailer
don't you think
feast your eyes on this
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three
ah
great
you're going to want to bust out your
best skills for kills and customize your
favorite class to their fullest most
brutal potential if you have the
pyromancer's burning desire to collect
every item of gear every weapon every
mod
and let's face it why wouldn't you then
listen up
this is end game and it is about to get
serious
let's get into the deets
hey there fellow outriders and welcome
to your biggest challenge yet
today we're going to take a closer look
at our new and much anticipated world
slayer end game
a vast and pretty damn scary place
called the trial of tarjakartar
quick disclaimer next to the overall
structure we'll be checking in on some
of the new gear available with world
slayer and we'll also take a look at one
of the new enemy types that are only to
be found in taryakratar other than that
we'll keep it spoiler free of course
we're also mostly soloing for the
purpose of the spotlight please keep in
mind as with so many things in life
there are even more fun when you team up
with friends and experience it together
enough chit chat end game let's get it
first things first you might ask
yourself what the heck is taria qatar
and why are we here in the first place
sadly we can't give you the full
background and history of this place
just yet because that's something for
you to explore as it is very much linked
to the world slayer story campaign
it's safe to say though without
revealing too much that this place is
deeply rooted in the legacy of planet
enoch's mysterious natives the pax
where's the father's power
this
madness
i gotta find out what the hell it was
let's start with an overview of tarjak
[ __ ] itself the trial takes place in a
new huge and fully explorable area
including changing weather day and night
time scenarios
it'll confront you with different combat
encounters and in some cases exclusive
enemies you'll need to stand victorious
after every encounter in order to delve
deeper into the heart of tario qatar
but make no mistake your enemies are
relentless and will even grow in
difficulty tears over the course of your
venture
every run starts at your base camp
conveniently set at the entrance to the
trial area here you will find all needed
amenities for your outrider lifestyle
[Music]
vendors
crafting
fast travel customize your character's
look access your stash find a party and
even access to all 18 previous
expeditions you'll be returned to your
camp if you manage to complete a full
trial run but also if you abandon an
attempt or simply die too often
[Music]
in any of those three cases tarjaktar's
rewards will reset and be freshly
obtainable
while exploring the dungeon you will
additionally encounter crossroads bus
arenas and trolls
crossroads may give you the opportunity
to explore areas of the primary path and
most of the time they will lead you to
trolls
bus arenas are mandatory to progress
deeper into tarjakatala
we are currently here
our first crossroads is giving us the
option to explore trove right from the
get-go
i will talk about the specifics of
troves a bit later
let's go and break some havoc first
by the way there's no time to element to
the trial
you can complete them at your own pace
and nobody will scream chop chop at you
while you stop smell the roses and just
take in the nice view from time to time
let's take a moment to go over our
current gear in pyromancer build we're
currently rocking a sanford submachine
gun the hellborne bolt action rifle and
the boulder links pistols we're also
doing this run with the pyromancer's new
heatseeker legendary armor set which
will work nicely with our equipped
pyroscales thermal bond overheat and ash
blast it has a wicked set bonus that
will activate once you successfully
manage to detonate an opponent with your
thermal bomb skill after the first
explosion thermal bomb will then
automatically travel to the opponent
with the lowest health and chains up to
three more times after the initial blast
the heatseeker set also comes with four
insanely powerful mods in support of our
overheat ability and helps to do some
serious damage we specialize the tempest
branch and the pyromancer skill tree for
this run
our pax class 3 specialization in the
pyromaniac branch will really help to
turn up the heat as just mentioned
heatseeker will enable our thermal bomb
to travel three more times after the
first impact those fireworks come with
50 reduced damage let's counted that a
little check out trigger sequence it
will give explosive skills like thermal
bomb 25 percent more damage and it
stacks up to three times boom
that's a great example of the importance
and fun to always be on the lookout for
exciting synergies between weapons mods
and skills
finally we're currently on essential
level 41. we've used our available
points to achieve a good spread of
increase in our four available main
categories anomaly power endurance
brutality and prowess however wellslayer
will also rework some existing gear
including the plagues ower and torturer
sets to ensure that your existing
favorite gear remains viable also keep
an eye out for our new sunfold
submachine gun special mod firestorm it
summons a violent and homing firestone
to deal damage and inflict an extra
crispy bird on enemies
the radius of the firestone will also
increase with each successful shot on
the afflicted target
that was fun
we'll swap to the hellbound bolt action
for the next encounter though
it will give you the violin rupture mod
creating a volcanic eruption on impact
now all those pyromancer players might
notice that this is actually one of the
pirates most brutal abilities so with
thermal bomb overheat and ash blast
already on our skill bar we essentially
added a fourth one on demand
nice
now's a great time to introduce you to
one of the trial's exclusive enemies the
shadow beasts
blink and you'll miss them but rest
assured
they won't miss you
these overwhelmingly effective predators
join the roster of monstrous adversaries
that you'll be facing shadow beasts are
the assassins of target [ __ ] and
usually appear in small packs
their sensitivity to the anomaly gives
them the ability to cloak themselves
even while in motion you may only be
able to track them if they disturb the
environment they pass through or by
using an aerial effect skill to unmask
them
shadow beasts use their superior
stalking capabilities to get close
enough to be able to attack you with
their special abilities
with the most debilitating of these they
will be able to inflict silence upon you
silence debuff locks the player's skills
from being triggered for a set duration
during this time you will need to rely
on your weapons only to fend off enemies
pretty nasty
i'd be also on the lookout for beast
lords
experienced feral hunters who managed to
tame these invisible killers and use
them as tracker
[Music]
we now have the option of progressing to
the first boss arena
or taking some time to investigate the
trove access from these crossroads
let's keep that boss waiting a little
longer as we mentioned earlier on trolls
are optional areas that you can explore
as you progress through tarjak qatar
they're dangerous enough to potentially
cut shore the dungeon run but the
rewards are well worth it
let's remind ourselves of why we're
already here
sweet sweet badass loot and trolls offer
something new to the outrider's universe
targeted apocalypse gear load farming
each trove will individually offer a
particular slot of gear
for example one trove will focus on
helmets while another will offer only
chest armor pieces completing a full run
of the trial of tarja gratar will reward
you with tons of new and amazing items
but these trove areas give you an added
opportunity to target and farm for
specific apocalypse variant gear to
complete your set given you make it out
alive from one of the trove areas you'll
be returned to your last crossroad and
can continue your journey each location
will challenge you in different ways
some of them will surprise you with
complete new enemy types since your last
visit
while others throw brand new boss
mechanics at you
again trolls are always a high risk
affair but high risk always comes with
high rewards outright as well slayer
so just to state the obvious the trial
of tarjak ratar is repeatable at any
point and designed with high
replayability in mind
guess we kept our first boss waiting
long enough
and i'll leave you now with a few
glimpses what's to come
we hope you will have hours and hours of
amazing fun entire guitar
take care and goodbye lovely people
[Music]
so
yeah
i told you endgame was going to be
brutal we have the new apocalypse system
crazy powerful third mod slots insane
new guns and gear devastatingly
beautiful environments monstrous enemies
you name it
i know what you're thinking is my
current class build gonna be powerful
enough am i good or mad enough to tackle
a solo run
well you would have my infinite respect
for beating end game by yourself but you
might want to bring along some company
to aid your battle through taya gratar
speaking of company where you at romney
it is time to break down those questions
and answers in another community section
thanks lucy what's good outriders
welcome to the community section of the
broadcast you have the questions and i
have the answers so let's jump right in
the first question we received a lot is
what are all the different versions of
world slayer
so we have two explosive options
available for you on june 30th
outriders worldslayer and the world's
their upgrade
for new players outright as well slayer
features everything worldslayer has to
offer and the original game included as
part of the package
for returning outrageous players the
world star upgrade is the product for
you just be sure to purchase on the same
platform you own the original game on
your characters and all of your progress
armor and weaponry will be transferred
seamlessly over to worldslayer so you're
fully ready to take on a rescue gal
one question we received consistently
was if wild slayer offered reasons to go
back to all the previous world areas
world slayer introduces apocalypse tears
to not only the new content but the
original outrageous game including
expeditions so you can replay or play
for the first time previous world areas
on the apocalypse did difficulty to
unlock associate rewards
apocalypse tiers are an addition to the
existing world tier difficulty system
increasing the difficulty increases the
quality of gear dropped a risk versus
reward system
improving the chances for both legendary
and apocalypse gear drops the best
weaponry and armor in the game
side note hunting for new gear
expeditions provides resources that you
can use to upgrade your current gear in
worldslayer so you can get a head start
on world style right now if you wish
we have worked hard to integrate cross
play between worldslayer and the
original outriders
so if you're a worldstare player and
have co-op partners who are still on the
original outriders there's nothing
stopping you from playing together on
the originals content
best of all you'll be able to jump into
their game of your what's their weapons
and armor
to confirm the new campaign and the
trial of tario guitar will only be
playable to people who own world's fair
or the world set upgrade so make sure
you do not miss out
we have a multitude of questions around
builds how the third mod slot works and
what weapons will still be viable
the outrider's ethos is allow you to
play however you want with whatever you
want
so if you do want to make a build that
focuses for example on your side arms as
your main weapon you absolutely can the
trigger twitch armor set will set you on
the right course
for everyone diving in streaming and
watching outriders on twitch we have
some great news for you
starting at launch and running for a
full week we'll be activating twitch
drops with handcrafted guns and gear
designed for each individual class
these can be obtained by anyone simply
by watching their favorite app riders
streamer on twitch
we'll be sharing more details around
this closer to launch so keep an eye out
for news
finally we are super excited to reveal
this absolutely stunning water
controller created by the legendary pro
part and will be available to players
via a community competition very soon
details on how to win its exclusive
controller will be made available by our
social channels so be sure to give us a
follow and stay tuned for your chance to
win this absolute beauty we'll see you
june 30th on enoch outriders back to you
lucy
thank you robbie
so outright is world slayer for new
players and the world slayer upgrade for
existing players are both available to
pre-order right now
and for a limited time if you do
pre-order you will receive a price
discount and 48 hours early access so
it's a no-brainer go and do the thing
i can't wait to gear up with sven and
robbie and tackle the horrors of world
slayer together
clearly i'm going to carry the team
where my trix domains at thank you for
tuning in to another outriders broadcast
i've been your host lucy and we will see
you all on enoch very soon goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you